hello
I guess relied good morning and today we
are hopefully all continuing on our
90-day challenge and three times a week
we get together and share our
experiences of studying I have my iPad
open so that I can see any comments that
come in here so now you may know that I
have you know I'm kind of dividing the
week off between Arabic and Persian and
typically the first half the week is
Arabic the second half is Persian in
some ways is not ideal because you know
you can't really focus concentrate on
one language no sooner are you really
getting am I getting my teeth into
Persian and I it's time to switch to
Arabic and I don't know why I decided to
do that but I decided to do that as an
experiment so here I am and so today I
go back into Arabic in fact normally I
would have gone back into Arabic
Saturday noon sort of thing and this
warms me up for my to online tutor
sessions with my Arabic tutor
however difference a different situation
this week because on Friday here in Palm
Springs where we live in this little
community we're having a party a
birthday party for my wife
and so we invited a bunch of people it
will have twenty or so people over and
one couple actually are originally from
Iran and I have never ever spoken to
them in Persian I've only spoken to them
in English and so of course I'm quite
keen to improve my Persian so that when
they come here on Friday I can surprise
them and actually speak to them in
Persian so therefore over the weekend I
mostly studied Persian I didn't study
any Arabic and so then of course knowing
that I have
tutor at 11 right after our session here
so last night I'm lying there and I met
for whatever reason I woke up and then I
start thinking how do you say this and
how do you say that in Arabic and the
only thing that came to my mind as I'm
lying there half asleep is Persian words
and of course the more I said because I
really gave myself sort of an extra dose
of Persia over the weekend so that my
brain is just clogged with Persian and I
couldn't think of it
so and and you know I don't know if
you've had this experience you lie there
you're trying to remember something and
you say forget it just go to sleep but
of course your brain won't let go so I'm
lying there I said forget it doesn't
matter doesn't matter and then if you
learn if you remember one the brain
immediately throws another one at you
now what is this in Arabic and I don't
know sorry I have to get up and check on
Google Translate on my iPad then I went
back to sleep so this kind of disrupted
my sleep so I slept in but the one you
know once I was up this morning making
breakfast again I was listening to
Arabic I will say that the sort of
overdose on Persian I didn't hinder my
comprehension if anything I found that
my comprehension of Arabic was better I
was hearing it more clearly and it kind
of reminded me that in language learning
the fundamental skill is comprehension
especially listening listening
comprehension everything else feeds to
that so I find that in order to remember
any words or learn anywhere to have to
see them written if I have an online
conversation with my tutor and my tutor
says you know this is how we say this in
Persian or Arabic until I see the word I
can't remember not a chance
so therefore I very much rely on the
conversation report that I then get from
my tutor and so then those new words now
become you know I'll lick them and then
they become part of the words that I'm
list of words that I'm trying to learn
so you know eleven o'clock I will be
speaking to MIT with my Arabic tutor and
it's my intention that immediately after
that one hour of Arabic I'm going right
back to Persian and I have another
Arabic session tomorrow at 10:00 but I'm
just gonna do Persia because I want to
be and this is where uh you know
specific motivation comes in I want to
be as good as I can be on Friday that's
the event that really matters when we
have this Persian couple coming over and
I get to speak to them the Persian so if
I struggle a bit with my Arabic cuter so
be it and maybe just half an hour or so
before I have my session with my tutor
I'll be listening to a bit of Arabic
just to warm up but I'll just be going
with whatever I have and I will report
back on Wednesday just how badly I do
but my main concern is going to be
comprehension and I think my
comprehension will be fine based on my
experience this morning comprehensively
fine and I'll be reaching for words and
there'll also be new words that my tutor
will give me and so it'll be part of my
learning experience so it's not like a
test and and that's in a wedding partly
why tests are such a bad thing because
people get as I am getting a little bit
concerned people are worried how will I
do
and we shouldn't as long as we keep
exposing yourself to the language and
developing that comprehension base the
rest will come so with that let me have
a quick look to see if there have been
any immediate questions and then I'll go
into sharing the screen oh one other
thought I had was since this is like a
study with me I often listen while doing
things like or stretching and stuff so
it would be needy I mean if there's any
interest we could do one where we all do
like a two-minute plank one-minute side
planks and then we do some stretching so
there would be 5-10 minutes while
listening to whatever we're learning
whatever language for learning so I
don't know if that would be of interest
but it's something that we could we
could do so that our study sessions
so become exercise sessions I we can't
really get much beyond that I could be
doing burpees or sit-ups with a little
more grunting there whereas a plank is
pretty quiet and we could all do that
and improve our physical fitness while
we're learning languages so let me know
what you think of that idea so as any
right before I share my screen oh and if
there are some specific aspects of Lake
I think a lot of the people to watch
these are link users and if there are
things in length that either you don't
understand
or you would like to see improved or any
comment about link please let me know
you can talk about your experience on
the web version on the either the
Android or the iOS app also if you are a
user about iOS apps or Android apps or
web bridge razor but especially with the
iOS and the Android app please rate link
we need to get as many as possible many
favorable reviews I mean you're gonna
review it honestly so whatever you think
about link please tell us bear in mind
though that five is a good review for is
not a good review the way these things
are and this now has become commonplace
in everything it doesn't matter what it
is wherever you are rating things if I
buy something on Amazon I'm asked to
rate it
people are so they pursue these I get
email messages if I buy I don't know
glassware or something for the party
whatever I get a follow up email or I
get I get even mail in there in you know
snail mail saying please review we rely
on the reviews please review so Martha
maybe we should be doing the same with
link please review it and if you like it
please give it a positive review now I'm
just quickly check here before I share
the screen okay so we start at the top
here I still see nothing because I
scheduled all right blah blah blah hey
Steve would you ever talk about ancient
languages would you ever learn Greek you
know what I learned
modern Greek I learned it well enough to
communicate when I was in Crete and that
I have to admit that I have now
forgotten a lot of it I still understand
to ask me now with my mind flow full of
Persian apathy sana mellitus or el Anika
Allah forgotten so but Morrison Morrison
Morrissey marciella Nika and I'll get
back to it okay thank you how did you
learn how did you learn Chinese okay you
know that was one occasion where I went
to school I had one-on-one instruction I
was paid by the Canadian government as a
diplomat to learn Chinese three hours a
day largely of drills and the rest of
the day reading and listening and
writing and so forth I did it over a
period of eight or nine months I
consumed everything I could find in the
language in those days there was no
later purpose so I would go out by
readers that had das trees and I would
and if possible with audio and I just
consumed input and that was where the
input based approach really worked
because I learned Chinese twice as fast
as the others who relied on their
classroom and I did this in Hong Kong
which is not a Mandarin speaking
environment no very few people in Hong
Kong in those days spoke Mandarin the
district attorneys okay oh I see you
don't know about the politics of every
country which like well when you say
know about I am interested in politics
so I know something about the politics
job every you know country whose
language I have learned I may have you
know wrong impressions are my love no
but maybe in fact is very superficial
but I know something is I'm interested
in this more specifically yes I can
write in Chinese I think I had that
question on her man's word yet when we
did our exam back 50 years ago the test
I had in
through this writing by hand translating
newspaper editorials from English into
Chinese from Chinese into English I had
to write in Chinese I had to write a
diplomatic note in Chinese but since
that time I have not written by hand so
I cannot write by hand in Chinese but I
can write on the computer in Chinese bla
bla bla
okay how do you stop translating from
Chinese to English in your head I've
dealt with this before you know to some
extent as we're learning a language
at first we do lots of translating and
gradually we do less and less the
translating helps us because we have to
refer to something thing we know so it's
quite normal to translate and it's only
with enough listening and reading that
all of a sudden the language is meaning
in its own right and we don't have to go
through translation but this simply
takes a lot and a lot of input which is
your biggest difficulty in Russian all
right Russian it's the big three the
cases for nouns and adjectives the
concept is very easy it's not that
difficult to understand why these cases
exist it's kind of corresponds to what
in other languages prepositions are used
for however to remember the correct
ending as you are speaking is difficult
that's why the next one is what they
call verbs of motion where you know to
go somewhere and come back is one verb
to go somewhere and go around do
different you know locations is another
verb to go on a means of transport
transport is another verb all of these
things are difficult again the concept
can kind of be understood but to try and
do these things on the fly is difficult
and the same is true with the aspects of
verbs perfective imperfective these
things no matter how often you read the
explanation it just takes a long long
time to get it right can you become
fluent in the language in six months in
sense of course you can but it depends
on the language it depends on which
languages you know could you speak in
let's say
okay alfalla fala portugues I will
probably the feces part of me but yeah I
gotta stop aprendendo o dó snake was a
me said my stomach on flute anyway
that'll do see Russian mini story number
24 has no translation on they can
notified do today we have all the tools
we need we just need to start thinking
in the language you're learning says
blood yeah easier said than done and you
can't just turn it on to start thinking
in the language you're learning it's
just something that naturally comes you
can't even will it it just comes because
the brain gradually gets used to it the
brain creates patterns and and all of a
sudden like you see is meaning and
you're no longer going through your own
language but it takes time how do you
improve your accent first like to want
to improve your accent like many people
immigrants in Canada live there all
their lives and never improve and
they're not concerned and they do fine
and they have a good command of the
language and no loss to have good
vocabulary and sometimes express
themselves better than native speakers
but they're not too fast about their
accent but if you want to improve your
accent I think a big part of it is
listening I knew an immigrant from China
and when I heard him speak I thought he
had been in Canada you know since he had
been you know a teenager is nothing he
had excellent excellent English
pronunciation and he said he listened to
the same CD a thousand times so if you
have the patience to do that it may be
that that works for you I have no idea I
haven't tried it I can't listen to
something for a thousand times however
when I start in the language I listen to
a limited amount of content 30 40 50
times because to pronounce something you
have to hear it you have to hear how
it's pronounced and at first we don't
hear at all so you listen and listen
listen and start you start to hear
exactly how the words are pronounced and
and I mean you can is some things are
obvious to you some things have to be
pointed out so sometimes the
pronunciation pronunciation explanations
can be helpful but not upfront it's like
with grammar when people sort of explain
to you at the beginning how things are
for now
when you haven't had a lot of exposure I
find that relatively meaningless
it's the same with grammar once you had
a lot of exposure to the language then
the explanations start to help you so
explanations can help you can also
listen to you know short piece of text
and then immediately try to record
yourself saying it in order to pick out
the differences what do you think about
extensive reading I think it's very good
and I practice both extensive and
intensive the intensive listening and
reading is more at the beginning stages
when I don't have enough vocabulary so I
certainly couldn't go off with a book I
need the help of Laney of online
dictionaries of the audio and I listen
many many times to get my brain used to
the language and then as my vocab better
it grows as I get past that ten thousand
word count fifteen thousand word count
at length then I'm better able to pick
up a book and start reading but
essentially the more you read the better
the more you listen the better so it's
simply you know even reviewing
flashcards is good you have to decide
given on given the time that you have
and what you'd like to do where you want
to spend your time and but I do a lot of
read no question through our primary
school we read in special books with
Chanukah I think it was a good
investment I think it is essential for
all beginners in Arabic native or not I
don't use the archive sorry to
disappoint you anything that I now that
I'm starting to pick my way through
articles from Al Jazeera from from house
my cats in it that have been transcribed
for me
they don't have how I cut on the
websites so I rely on a good portion of
material that I have in Arabic first of
all has an audio natural voice audio so
I can listen listen listen read listen
listen when I read after a while I hear
again what I have listened to so often
and so I'm starting to get useful and
I'm sort of resigned to the fact that in
Arabic eventually the words that I will
be able to read will be words that I
already know and so therefore I
recognize the word much as I would
and as a Chinese character and I will
not be relying on the haricot so that's
been my approach I just have I can see I
find too that the haricot clutters up
the page I know what they do but I don't
need them at least I don't use them
could be I'm wrong yeah no do you think
Moses approach to talking to people
until you can't talk anymore or it's
affected I don't do that like that is
not a deliberate strategy obviously if
I'm standing in line at the grocery
store and somebody behind me is speaking
Arabic or Farsi person I will turn
around and try and engage them but I
won't deliberately walk into an Arabic
store and start to you know and
certainly not with a camera turned on I
wouldn't do that I don't think you can
talk yourself to fluency even if you are
those who are in favor of talking as a
means of you know building up your your
skill and the language right from the
beginning speaking from day one kind of
things where they are learning is
because they are triggering input for
them by saying something to which the
native speaker responds and hopefully
then they learn what the native speaker
said that's particularly effective if
you're with an online tutor because I
get a rapport with an audio recording in
fact when I speak with my tutor I can
get into subjective in it just like last
week with my Persian tutor know in the
past we've spoken about you know
political things economic things but I
said today I have these friends coming
over they're originally from Iran let's
talk about food and stuff like that and
we spoke about food and then I get the
report and so I can review if I trigger
input so that speaking is a means of
triggering input input that's relevant
to you meaningful to you and so you
learn from the input I don't believe you
learn from speaking to people what are
they paneer so kanopolis Almario they're
Garrett's say how often marry Maya what
do you think about the Thai language I
mean what do I think about any languages
I think languages are phenomenal a
language is something that was created
by people initially simply to
communicate you know give me this
you know I love you whatever and that
have evolved into these amazing
embodiments of the culture of a specific
people every language is phenomenal I
don't care whether it's the Eskimo
language or Innuit language rather or
you know the click-click language in the
Kalahari Desert or Chinese or you know
Portuguese they're all phenomenal and if
I have the time and if we get Thai at
link I will try to learn Thai I'm a
little bit you know the brain is getting
my brain is getting more and more
clogged with different writing systems
and different vocabulary so it may be
that I say you know to take on Thai
writing and tones is too much for me but
in terms of the respect that I have for
the Thai language for that culture of
course I respect it very much but giving
them one piece of advice to learn
Chinese patience learn the characters
first of all that's a big part of the
Chinese language you are entering into a
new world
phenomenal cultural world the characters
a big part of it make that investment
which means every day working on your
characters and then just do a lot of
listening reading don't get too hung up
about the tones they will come
especially if you learn you know phrases
and learn to say phrases naturally the
tones will come but it'll take it's like
everything in language learning we
learned what we learn slowly so patience
patience hello Steve what do you think
of taking language exams for language
certificates in terms of motivations
well it depends if that's what motivates
you go for it but I am NOT motivated
like I don't really want the stress I
enjoy the language now obviously when I
was at school and we had French in
Montreal of course had to write the test
but I mean we just had to do it wasn't
so much motivation it's something that
we had to do bear in mind that in
english-speaking Canadians schools
everyone has tests most kids pass the
tests and
very few people can speak French so the
test didn't do much when I had my
Chinese studies I've been paid by the
government so obviously I had to write
the text but since then with all the
languages that I have learned I have
never written any test and I have no
interest in writing any test for any
language any good French book
suggestions for an intermediate learner
see an intermediate learner to me is
someone who can read and so therefore
it's a matter of what are you interested
in you know personally when I would say
intermediate in Russian I would buy
audio books and they have in Russia they
have phenomenal audio Russian theater
movies audio books everything is
theatrical that you so well and so to
the French and then because I like 19th
century literature told story and to
gain you have and stuff then I would
find those texts on the Internet
bring him into link we can import whole
books into length so I'd be listening to
audiobooks while jogging or while
cross-country skiing and then I go back
to link and work through the vocabulary
I know that even though I I studied
French and then I studied in France for
three years and my French was obviously
very good because I passed you know a
young boy I did quite well in fact all
in French oral exams in French written
exams in French but maybe 10 or 15 years
ago I listened to a number of French
audiobooks now I don't didn't really
need to review them at may because I
know almost the words but just in terms
of listening to Balzac or any you know
French audiobook listen to the beautiful
language spoken so well that's very very
good for your skills and I believe that
improve my French skills that just let's
think all those are three books so I
would say fine stuff that you're
interested in listen and read listen and
read listen and read and I can't tell
you what you should be interested in now
any good friendship
okay do you think all grammar can be
acquired by input and comprehensible
input okay no I don't agree with that it
can because it's all about it's a bit
like the pronunciation there are things
we notice on our own or things that we
get used to our neuron we not actually
pick up and we do there are things that
we simply don't notice and so I find
that I refer to grammar regularly right
now I'm going through I have a book a /
a Persian you know I think it's a living
language or whatever I'm going through a
chapter after chapter to go after some
of the grammar explanations and grammar
examples and examples are much more
important than explanations but
typically they introduce a concept here
such and such a tense in Persian they
get a long explanation of things that
I'm not that interested in because
basically I've seen that but then they
give you 10 examples of this and it
refers these are examples of things that
I have already experienced so I find
that very useful and then I have a book
of Persian verbs and every verb has all
of the different conjugations so I find
that a when you are interested in
understanding something better then you
go to the grammar or when you have
already experienced a lot of things then
you go to the grammar and of course when
you come away from having looked at the
grammar you don't remember it but it
just is another step towards being able
to internalize the grammar it helps it
helps you notice things it helps you
this that's my experience it helps you
get used to it so I think where they do
things wrong in traditional instruction
is they teach you the grammar upfront
before you have the experience like they
try to teach you the pronunciation
before you've heard enough of the
language but once you have that exposure
to the language you then benefit by
going back into some examples is it papa
Steve I'm strongly considering subscribe
your link aside from the many stories
what is the usual progression route
within Lake it's a matter of what
language now historically we had who is
she who is she is not as good as the
many stories like I I'm a person
a great believer in the many stories but
I'll if I look at my experience with
Greek Persian and Arabic so I go many
stories and I listen to some of the
earlier ones 30 40 times and then listen
lesson that's frequently as you go along
then I went to who is she which is more
difficult and then typically I look
around to see what's in our library if I
find stuff of interest there and that's
gonna depend on the language and if not
certainly in any language where you're
not dealing with a difficult or a
different writing system like if it's
you know written in the Latin alphabet
then I can very quickly go oh to online
articles or podcasts or even books with
audio so it's a matter of you exploring
googling seeing what's out there but I
think if if you know out of our link
library the many stories who is she
those are basic we have translations for
all of them I know that depending on the
language there's lots of other good
content in Russian it's very rich German
so it depends on your language explore
what's there and then go and see what's
on the internet that you can import into
link is it possible to learn foreign
language at the same time I guess it's
possible I'm finding it very difficult
to because don't forget I'm not a full
time language student you know my wife
likes to play golf we have friends we do
different things he's difficult I like
to watch the vancouver cannot play a
hockey and there are a bit of a bear for
punishment there so for that would be a
lot okay
it's got a seven day trial unit yeah I'm
a beginner here in Swedish and have
finished the mini stories but I'm
starting to find a new course because
they're all too hard for me as a not
very common that yeah it's a problem we
need more sort of intermediate level
content I haven't been doing Swedish and
lifting I don't know what's there just
let that go away yeah Swedish again
Swedish you know it's it's if I were you
I would started reading newspaper
articles newspaper typically is easier
because very often we know the context
in English for exam
they say that newspaper articles are
written at a grade 7 grade 8 level so or
if you can find things on Swedish
history generally speaking nonfiction
and translations from English essay are
easier than say a piece of literature
and so I would go explore those secrets
you can import I talked talked it up on
our forum our Swedish forum or content
forum see what advice other members have
do you have any book recommendations for
Spanish advanced level reading well we
do have some audio books in our library
at link political dos I think Trafalgar
is one but I mean there's lots of good
Spanish books out there's lots of good
Spanish books out there or for that
matter maybe also in Swedish and in in
Spanish go to go to youtube and if there
are videos with subtitles
then our import extension enables you to
bring the video in as a lesson and the
text appears as a less as less than text
the audio is available for download and
you can still see the video so that
might be a source for material but boy
you know look up the bestsellers going
to iTunes and switch to Spain or Swiss
switch to a spanish-speaking country and
see what's there
you know I think we have to get into the
habit of looking for stuff looking for
content that suits our needs do you
think Doolin was a good at no I tried it
for Greek and I tried it for Hebrew and
for a Greek I mean it just throws up
what seemed to me I didn't get into it
deeply enough but it just throws up a
bunch of disjointed not very interesting
not very sensible phrases I mean nah I
just to me first of all the idea that
that they begin by using you know
pictures of dog are free and I find
those of limited benefit I'd like to get
into words words within meaningful
context workers with audio basically
what we have a link so I'm not a great
fan of duolingo it does have the
advantage that it's free why don't we
have the
the download our links into x XE XE
document I'm not an expert but I think
there is something like that can you
either comment on our forum or send an
email to customer service at link and
they should be able to explain that I
think there is an ability to to move of
the links into some kind of a I don't
know what an exe document is but yeah I
think okay here is it possible to add an
S in your course into link we have we
have tried with SML to you know have
them sell their courses across link they
kind of show some interest and then they
don't reply what I did because I have
the audio for both the Arabic and the
Farsi in the Persian so I actually paid
someone to transcribe it so I have the
SML course in link but it's only for my
own use because we don't have that
copyright to share that but I had to pay
someone to transcribe it based on the
audio that now I know that Erik in our
shop has suggested that you can also
photocopy that the with your iPhone
scanner on your iPhone it works to take
pictures of lessons and then import them
and he did up he did a video on that
maybe he can put that up here in the
description box so you can try doing it
that way
can I speak okay Anna Leigh Leigh I
study Laurel arabiya Eliana
you know
Leon missionaries Persian
other so others a lot of fallacy ax Ella
delica mini Saba optical Abdullah Al
Arabiya waking at the minion bother yes
let's see what would I say it's so good
I'm gonna stop I tell you my Arab I've
been so heavy to parse in my Arabic is
kind of in bad shape
but I will be speaking in Arabic I will
be speaking in Arabic when I maybe had a
couple of days of straight Arabic and my
mind isn't cluttered with Farsi question
hasty I have one month to be able to be
somewhat fluent in Japanese enough to
speak a 15 minute card what Stefan said
you know there are no magic steps I
would lots of listening reading previous
verse eeeh spasibo za za za za Yeti
thank you very much
I must say I I do love I love all the
languages but I really love my exposure
to Russian I will be in Ukraine second
half of May and largely in eastern
Ukraine so I will be speaking a lot of
Russian there and I think my Russian
well maybe take a step forward what do
you think about taking language
certificate exams as a means of
motivation okay I am not motivated that
way but if people are then obviously
that's a good thing
can I learn any language alone you know
you're not alone because you're engaging
with the language you're engaging with
audio you're engaging with text so in a
way you're you're not alone but you can
do it without a teacher I definitely oh
yeah here is I signed up link to read
investment in improving my polish how
difficult a polish for you
Romanian is a lot easier than polish
Romanian
is 70
Sen latin-based vocabulary 20% Slovak
baseball cap you Larry the grammar is
not overly complicated it was easy
polish is more difficult no question and
especially if you don't have other
Slavic languages but they're all well
worth 10 years yeah interact with native
speaker is important do you speak do you
speak Japan I speak Japanese you know
with the Damacio thank you I hope you
get Thai on link it's such a beautiful
language if we get enough content we'll
put it on link do you get situated on
solution think about me for my mom I
play busy the last house so it depends
on the language obviously I'm having
real trouble right now switching out of
Farsi into any other language it depends
how how solid your base is I find that
any language where I have done a lot of
listening and reading and speaking
preferably again say my top ten
languages I can switch not a problem
beyond that it becomes very difficult ok
your videos are motivating thank you
what do you struggle with Mormon
learning a language in the intermediate
phase listening reading and speaking
what are your thoughts on active versus
passive listening ok I mean initially
the hardest thing obviously is listening
because you can read I can look up words
so my initial sort of first step is to
get to where I can actually understand
what I'm listening to
once I cannot understand what I'm
listening to then I work on my speaking
and active versus passive listening I
mean I don't know what active listening
is I listen sometimes while reading
especially with with the writing system
that's different like with Persian or
Arabic but much of my activity is
passive I'm listening in reading if you
call that passive but I am interacting
with the language so to that extent is
active some people fuss about whether
their active vocabulary isn't as big as
their passive vocab
it's gonna be the active vocabulary will
be smaller always the native
speaker will probably know more words
but you need a wide passive vocabulary
to understand what native speakers are
saying okay do do you know about summer
air and I use the languages no I know
nothing about rare and unusual languages
what is your opinion about monolingual
dictionaries I don't use monolingual
dictionaries
if I am good enough in the language that
an explanation in the language that I'm
studying is gonna do it for me fine but
that's not usually the case usually if I
use a monolingual dictionary I then
encounter more words that I don't know
and since my learning is based on
dealing with interesting content if I'm
then distracted into the library into
the dictionary and I'm constantly
looking at words in order to understand
what a particular word is that's not
very satisfying for me so I always use
bilingual dictionaries what is your
opinion of okay where is Eric I don't
know does link accept other currencies
again someone else will have to answer
okay linked okay Erika's answered at
Yuanyuan with you a ha ha
your shirt's a Qatar Li Yin guides up a
young your dog shows on the okay so how
should a teacher in a classroom lead the
sort of learners I think if I were a
teacher I would encourage them to you
know develop their comprehension skills
don't worry about mistakes you make but
spend a lot of time getting a sense of
the language reading things of interest
listening to things meant just building
up your vocabulary us make mistakes
pronounce it wrong it doesn't matter
like I would not test kids I would not
test kids on their output I would
measure kids on their level of activity
how many words that you read today how
many hours have you been listening what
are you reading on what are you
listening to
and encourage them into this sort of
absorbing the language and don't worry
about what you can say until you
actually can understand a lot so that
would be the approach that I would take
that would not necessarily go over well
with the school administration or with
the parents but that's what I would do
okay I'm a changed man hello sir since
everybody's definitely fluency is
different I would like to know what
yours is okay to me fluency is b2 on the
European scale that is to say that you
can speak with some difficulty with some
missing words with some mistakes but you
can have an easy conversation with
people on a variety of subjects they're
not struggling to understand you you're
not struggling to understand them but
you are far from perfection that next
level c1 c2 is where you're moving
towards perfection but b2 is just you're
comfortably able to speak all right I
have usually four right here and I'm
approaching one many words you read I
still have problems with comprehension
what is a good ratio of listening versus
other activities I listen more than
anything else because it's easier to
arrange so to read them to link I got to
sit down I got a fine half an hour or a
34 minutes to do it the listening I can
do so many different times so I end up I
would say 60% listening 30% reading 10%
checking out grammar issues no no how do
you progress from understanding language
to actually writing and speaking it well
eventually you have to start doing those
things and you'll do them with
difficulty but at some point when you
feel up to it and I found myself like
right now I'm speaking to my person
Twitter after about 1,500 no words at
length with Arabic it's like 7,500 no
words but in the past I felt that when I
was at 15,000 words then I could really
go out to speak and you just have to
start doing and you do it with mistakes
you do it with all kinds of difficulty
but the more you do it the better you
get part of it is forcing yourself to
retrieve words that you have in your
system forcing yourself to activate
things that have
come part of your brain and part of it
is that you trigger a bunch of new words
that come back at you if you have an
online tutor I think for example okay
when will you have Hungarian on like
okay wait a second I jumped ahead of
myself okay when you learn polish you
ever spend myself studying the grammar
in cases okay yeah I go over these
things as I done no don't forget that
when I got the Polish I had already done
Russian Ukrainian and checked so a lot
of the basic grammatical features of all
of these Slavic languages are extremely
similar but I would review those but the
bulk of my time was spent listening and
reading
I moved very quickly with Polish because
there's so much similar vocabulary to
Ukrainian or Czech I move very quickly
to audiobooks where I could buy the
e-book yeah poop leo I think it was
pointed dog PL which I imported in the
link so most of my time is spent
listening and reading occasion referring
to you know grammar when we have
Hungarian are linked when someone
provides us with the many stories
translated in India Jared oh hey Steve I
won laughs we've done that hello huh
thank you have you tried link oh dear no
it's the maximum is 20 hi Roger
how do you add your own stuff into link
if I could go I'm not gonna do it today
because we're running out of time here
but I will give you I did it before I
will do it again I will show you how you
import but there is in link the an
import feature both on the web I know in
the web I think in the app we now have
it on the iOS but I will do that next
time
bla bla bla how to work intensive on how
to work intensive on language grammar
the way I do it is intensive listening
and reading occasional reference to
grammar no exercises drills all the
stuff that they fill the textbooks with
forget it I don't think it does much ba
ba ba ba did you use and answers ok I
see Thanks what do you think about study
2 languages at the same time I'm doing
it right now
it has its difficulties it keeps things
interesting but it's it's easier to
focus on one the advantage of two of
course is that you if you're getting
bored with one you switch to the other
I'm learning Mandarin Chinese I started
asking about three months I could really
understand anything listening and could
speak pretty much nothing
alright thank you Steve for creating
making videos I think the Larry's or any
experience that you're showing with
those process and literally change Bobby
that's good great did you consider
seeking to work with a company that
could offer our audio need books and
then sell a service really yes we would
love to we've approached various
publishers they I think don't consider
us important enough or they're afraid of
copyright issues or whatever but so far
no no well a few we have some Benny the
Irish probably God has some stuff for
that link and so we have had some
limited success would you concerning
land consider learning languages like a
slanted Icelandic Tibetan or from there
no I'm not particularly motivated right
now because it's just I don't have any
you know opportunity to interact with
people from there there's not a lot of
speakers it's not next on my list let's
put it that way I understand you but I
can't speak help me what can I do speak
more
hi Steven your experiences our speakers
from some languages countries more
welcoming to language learners
yes definitely and I tell you the
Persian speakers are just about the most
welcoming I've ever come across
yo mm okay most people aren't perfectly
in their native language hi you are an
inspiration please could you say we had
to teach them yeah it's dr. Gavin
schedule Barsky Magoo no accessory usage
hacia party Nika I know your policy I
promote more Yerevan a discovery izakaya
not gay orgy anyway my best language is
Mandarin but at least I can use dinner I
can actually talk okay
you know how many months have you been
stuff don't forget that it's more than
I've got non-chinese Peter so give
yourself a bit of credit - hi Steve I'm
an American
in Portugal trying to learn Portuguese
by learning teaching it approach of any
specific suggestions get on link get on
leg lots of material in our libraries
yeah get on it and and use the language
the Portuguese speak English very well
so it's a bit of a challenge at times
that I tend to risk lying in English but
I found that I was eventually able to
overcome that and you can also search
our library for material in Portuguese
from Portugal European Portuguese
mini-story for Thai blah blah blah well
if someone can scare up some mini stores
in time we will definitely upload we got
Gujarati we got Gujarati of course we're
gonna load up tiles how many languages
are you fluent in well depends on the
word fluent but as I defined it I think
I'm you know eight or ten or so and then
the others are somewhat lower level okay
I mean I speak 11 lengths but I'm not at
all motivated by tests but I'm not an
ADA you speak just hard to stay with
Baba speak 3 and I really beat you learn
I started then how can I study
all I heard is in my routines I don't
know you have to figure out how much
time you have available if you have one
language that you speak particularly
well
you can learn third language based on
the second language today I can
understand you why I don't understand
movies I don't know how we should listen
to foreign should I pay attention all
the time yeah you can't pay attention
all the time not simply not possible so
so much in language sorry we have to
accept that things are not perfect so
I'm listening and I fade out I played in
my wife says something interrupts me but
it's it's all exposure so I don't worry
about being focused all the time I don't
worry about but I don't understand
listen don't forget I'm missing too some
of these things 3040 times so what I
missed the one time I get the next time
then I go back and read it's not a
problem and blah blah blah how do you
prepare for working with a tutor then
what do you talk about I'm terrified
awkward silence all right first of all I
don't normally talk to a tutor until I
had at least 1500 words now in Farsi I
used to wait till I had like 8,000 words
because I was a bit scared like you know
what I do is I speak to the tutor I
don't prepare no special preparation
except I'm supposed to speak in Arabic
in you know 15 minutes and I'm gonna
really struggle because I haven't done
anything
typically I like to have an hour or two
of listening and come by getting warmed
up at least and then I speak with my
tutor she usually it's been she she
gives me a long list of words and
phrases that I tried to use I get this
as a report usually with the audio and
so it's it's generating relevant content
it's not a test I'm not concerned about
where I struggle and of course you have
to have a good tutor good Skype
connection person who asks you questions
you don't have to think of what to talk
about they keep you going
so in that and on that basis I enjoy it
I'm concerned but this is a language for
each other not to be you mispronounced
khmer most i'll get video learning to
make some mistakes or learn each yeah i
mean learning two languages you're gonna
program a course mode
do you think the more people learn other
languages the more peaceful the world
becomes no unfortunately the immediate
example it comes to mind is the former
Yugoslavia they all spoke the same
language
not to mention Northern Ireland so
there's no there's no evidence that
people who share each other the same
language don't manage together at each
other's throats okay thanks it's an hour
a day enough for Spanish it's enough if
that's what you have it's enough it's
good who is this Michael Green guy yeah
okay Brazilian who do you consider a
polyglot I would say three languages are
more pew died everybody has since pew
die pie have no idea what that is
okay I'm off I got it I'm gonna listen
to at least 10 minutes of Arabic so I
don't make a fool of myself in my
conversation with my Arabic tutor and
thank you bye for now